نحن الان في مدينه جنديرس في ريفي عفرين
كما نشاهد هنا الصوره خلفنا تتكلم هذه
الابنيه التي تدمرت بسبب الزلزال الذي وقع
سفجره اليوم عدد كبير من الابنيه كما
نشاهدها هنا وهذا البناء ايضا هناك فرق
الدفاع المدني تعمل في عده مواقع هنا في
مدينه
واستنفرت كافه
عناصرها ولكن هذه العناصر من الدفاع
المدني لا تكفي ولا ولا تغطي كل المناطق
فما هنا نشاهد عناصر من فصائل المعارضه
تساعد على هاله بالاضافه الى ان الاهالي
ايضا تعمل على
انقاذ والبحث عن جين تحت هذا الدمار مدينه
جنديرسيه الاكثر تضررا في منطقه ريف حلب
وبالاضافه الى مدينه الاتارب حتى الان لا
يوجد احصائيات واضحه جدا هناك الى الان
عدد كبير بحسب افاده الينا الاهالي عدد
كبير من الاهالي تحت الانقاض وهو ما يرجح
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا هذه الابنيه التي
مقتطفه بالسكان بحسب ما قال لنا الاهالي
وهي كثيره داخل هذا هذا هذه الاحياء حتى
اننا نقف على هذا الردم دمار الابنيه
اضرار كبيره لحقت بالمنطقه هنا نشاهد ايضا
يقومون
بانتشال الضحايا وجمعها
الى المشافي اضرار كبيره وفرق دفاع مدني
تعجز عن
تغطيه كافه هذه الاضرار بالاضافه الى ان
الامطار تزيد من معاناه الاهالي وتزيد من
صعوبه الموقف بشكل كبير محمد جزائري
الجزيره ريفو حلب